On Wednesday,
uh,
I would like you to, uh, you know, come,
having read one of
Steven's is longer poems.
Um, it's not too long, but it's a
little longer, uh, the words of autumn,
uh, which is a wonderful poem.
It's not exactly timely, uh,
at this moment, but, um, uh, please, uh,
please come having thought
about it, uh, as you,
as you read it, um, think about, um,
images that you find in the
poem of Stars of the theater,
uh, of, um,
images of mother and father. Uh, poem is
full of both. Uh, a friend
asked me the other day,
are there any happy poets?
Uh,
well, and of course, no, there aren't,
or at least not any that
are any good, right? Um, no,
that's, that's not true. Um,
in fact, as I think
about the syllabus, um,
Williams is a happy poet.
You know,
he caused himself the happy
genius of his house, uh, hold, uh,
in that little poem dance reus he's
talking about running around the house
naked. Uh, Marianne Moore I think
in many ways is a happy poem.
Uh, but, uh, no poet is so happy, uh,
as well as Stevens. Uh,
and Stephen's is, um,
he is happy,
uh,
in the sense that he is a comic poet.
Uh,
and that doesn't mean that you're going
to laugh a lot while you read while
Steven's though you might sometimes and,
and he can be silly,
uh, though that's perhaps
not his strongest vein. Uh,
Steven's is, is, uh, a
comic poet in the sense, um,
uh, in the generic sense
of, of, uh, a poet, uh,
in whom and for whom and with whom
the world always comes, right. Um,
the world is right and good.
Uh, it is a regenerative, uh,
exhilarating,
endlessly.
I'm consoling and
meaningful place to dwell.
Uh, and, and Steven says,
uh, you know, really, uh,
as I read him every year,
um,
I like him more and more and
becomes more and more important.
Uh,
Steven's gives us a really a
comprehensive view of the world,
uh, and one in which, uh,
poetry and imagination
have central roles to play.
Uh,
imagination.
That's an important word
in Steven's. Uh, it's,
it's a word he takes right out
of British romanticism. Uh,
and the long tradition of romantic poetry.
And Stevens is a though in complex ways.
Uh,
Leichhardt crane and, uh, a, um,
defiantly romantic,
modern poet.
Uh, Steven's is poetry like Morris, uh,
like cranes.
Uh,
to some extent like frost is always
in a sense met up poetry that is,
uh, well he shares with these
poets as with certain others,
uh, on our syllabus. Um,
the sense that poetry has to always
involve and investigation into its own
rules, how it works, uh, what
it does, what it's capable of.
Uh, what it's potential uses are. Uh,
and that all of these are in a
sense open, uh, and uh, available,
um, to, uh, redefinition
and a fundamental level.
Uh, he says there's a
wonderful set of, uh,
adages is or, um, epigrams or, uh,
statements, uh, at the back of your book
which come from, uh, Steven's, his dad.
Gea.
Uh,
one of those statements is all
poetry is experimental poetry.
Uh,
and there's a sense in any Stevens poem,
uh, that, uh, Steven's is going to, uh,
is experimenting and is
going in some new direction,
not just at the beginning of the
poem, but throughout the poem. Uh,
that's how it proceeds. Uh, you
could compare this idea, uh,
to Williams is, uh,
interest in newness, uh,
and a,
um,
a sense of life as always
subversive of life, uh,
preceding. Uh, it's a
related idea for, uh,
Steven's, uh, in his, uh,
poetry in his poem, um, of modern poetry,
which is a little a essay on the
subject of what is modern poetry.
Uh, Steven says, um,
it has to construct a new stage,
uh,
and it not only has to construct that
new stage, it has to be on it too. Uh,
and there's a way in which Stevens,
his poems are both, uh, you know,
creating a new space in which to speak,
uh,
and they're speaking from there.
These two things are going on at once.
Uh, Steven's also says, uh,
in that set of a Diageo,
um, uh, and they're wonderful,
uh, provocative ones, uh,
throughout a poem is a
pheasant, uh, for one, uh,
he also says poetry is a means of
redemption and it's on page nine 72.
Poetry is a means of redemption.
He meant it.
He meant it,
uh,
for Steven's poetry stands in
the place that religion wants.
Did,
uh,
other poets that we've read this semester,
look to poetry, to serve different
functions, uh, of religion.
I think, um, for Elliot,
uh, he is concerned with
ritual and community, uh,
in ways in which poetry might
establish these, constitute these,
uh, more is, uh,
the most well with
Elliot, the, the most, uh,
uh, serious Christian,
uh, is, is concerned, uh,
with poetry as a, as a model for
ethical action as a kind of guide, uh,
uh, for conduct in the
world. Uh, and, and, uh,
poetry models for her,
what she calls love or hope or striving,
uh,
or doing hard things,
for Steven's poetry takes over,
uh,
another dimension of religious experience.
Uh,
power poetry takes over Christianity's
traditional concern with redemption.
Uh, and with redemption, uh, with
questions about the afterlife,
Paradise, uh, the transcendental,
how can culture imagine the transcendental
in a non transcendental world?
Uh,
how can it imagine the metaphysical
in a non metaphysical world?
How can we have heaven
if we don't have god?
These are all questions in
Stephen's his poetry. Uh,
he answers them,
uh,
in ways that that put him on heart
cranes side of the debate with Elliot,
uh, in the wasteland, the
decay of Sacred Authority, uh,
this is a crisis of community of meaning
language has sort of lost its meaning,
uh,
for crane.
This condition rather than
a crisis as an opportunity,
an opportunity for poetry
to lend a myth to God.
Elliot is disturbed to see God,
uh, as something constructed,
something linguistics,
something we might lend a myth to only
lend it in a sense that we're going to
have to bring it back. Uh, for crane, uh,
for Steven's,
God always was a myth,
a metaphor and metaphors can and need
to be exchanged in renewed all the time.
Uh, in this crane and Stevens
are very close together.
Let's, um, let's look at
an early palm of while Stevenson early
grand poem called Sunday morning.
Uh,
the first one in your Steven's selection,
it's on page two 37,
uh,
Sunday morning.
It was published in
Poetry magazine in 1915,
uh, which is to say it's
contemporary with Prufrock,
uh, roughly contemporary with
Marianne Morris. A grave,
both poems that appeared in poetry to
uh,
well let's read this first stanza.
Complacency's of the pain wire and lake
coffee in orange is in a sunny chair and
the green freedom of
a cockatoo upon a rug.
All these things mingle to dissipate
the holy hush of ancient sacrifice.
Okay.
She dreams a little
and she feels the dark encroachment
of that old catastrophe,
that old catastrophe being the crucifixion
as a calm,
dark and among water lights,
or if it's not the crucifixion,
it's
the fall.
The pungent oranges and bright green wings
seem things in some procession of the
dead winding across wide
water without sound.
The day is like wide water without sound
stilled for the passing of her dreaming
feet over the seas to silent Palestine.
Dominion of the blood and sepal occur.
This is a poem about,
uh, not going to church,
uh, about doing something
else with Sunday morning.
Uh, it announces, or it
takes for granted really
a great change in culture
change and the cultural order,
uh,
where Sunday morning is
no longer spent or need,
not necessarily always be spent at church.
Uh,
Steven's is writing about,
in some ways the end of the Christian era.
Of course, it's going on, but in a,
in a different form from
what it had been known as a,
you can think about how
unlike this poem is,
uh, how, how, excuse me, how, uh,
how little this poem is like,
uh,
a poem on a similar theme in Yates
such as the second coming, uh,
where the end of Christianity is an
apocalyptic event and there's some rough
beast slouching towards Bethlehem.
Uh,
instead in Stevens,
the power of the past,
the Christian area simply dissipates,
poof,
uh, dissolves, uh, in the
circumstances that he's describing.
What is it,
what is a pain new are,
uh, I, I think Steven's
likes the French word. Uh,
this is, this is a dressing gown.
Um, we have a female figure here,
uh,
presented to us in a space of domestic,
bourgeois luxury comfort,
um,
a complacency even,
uh,
with coffee and oranges
and a cockatoo.
Uh,
whether that cockatoos
actually a bird or, or, um,
uh, design in the rug, uh,
critics have disagreed.
Uh, you can, uh, you can, you
can make that bird what you like.
Um,
this female presence that we're
introduced to is a figure for the poet,
uh, an unnamed, she, that
the poem will be about
she,
uh,
embodying poetic sensibility,
a poetic thinking and poetic impulses,
uh,
seems to place poetry in this
space of domestic comfort,
uh, seems to identify
poetry with the feminine,
with a female perspective,
uh, and with consumption, uh,
with fine imported goods,
uh,
as you will find elsewhere.
And Steven's, uh,
uh, identifies a life of
ease with the imagination.
Uh, Steven's is poetry, uh,
like Yates is in certain ways a
though I'm very different terms,
what we're even here, like Elliot's, uh,
presents us with a number of very powerful
female figures with whom the poet,
uh,
identifies his own creativity.
This is an important one. A, and
there there's a, there's a, um,
uh,
what w uh,
there's an aspect of Steven's that's
gendered as feminine. You could say,
ah,
it's that aspect of Steven's
that identifies with poetry
as a space apart from
the masculine world of work.
Uh,
contrast this with Frost, uh, who, uh,
uh, Steven's identify as poetry
with subjective freedom, uh,
space, uh, apart from objective necessity,
what frost is always responding to.
Uh,
Steven's maintains a complex
attitude, however, uh,
towards this,
um,
identification of poetry with
aspects of culture that are,
are gendered, uh, as,
as female. Uh, there,
there's a macho strain in
Stevens to, uh, often, uh,
a hyperbolic in somewhat comic,
one in which Stevens is
identifying with a giant big men.
Uh, and, and I'll talk more about
that. Uh, two lectures from now.
Um, uh, in this poem, um, I think,
uh, well possibly, uh,
warding off the anxiety
of identifying poetry.
So, uh, clearly and strongly
with, uh, the female, uh,
Steven's includes in, um, stands a seven
on a two 39 to 40. Uh, I,
I kind of parodic
celebration of masculinity,
supple and turbulent.
A ring of men shall chant an orgy on a
summer more in their boisterous devotion
to the sun, not as a god, but as
a god might be naked among them,
like a savage source.
And so on. This is a,
this is another vein of
Stevens, his imagination, and
it's here in this poem, uh,
in again,
almost hyperbolic comic form.
Uh, if Stevens is, is, uh, uh,
anxious about, uh, identifying, um, uh,
poetry with, um, uh, the,
uh, the feminine. Uh,
I think that's because in a sense as
Steven sets things up here at this early
point in his career,
all poets are women poets
on Sunday morning. Uh,
poetry can only be written
on Sunday morning, uh,
or on the weekend or after
hours at the end of the workday.
Uh, uh, these are the
spaces in which, uh, uh,
in his life, uh, um, poetry exists.
But more generally, these are the sort
of cultural spaces that, that, uh,
the Times that, uh, Steven's, um,
identify as poetry with,
uh, here in this poem.
Uh, uh, Steven's is, is in
a sense brooding on, um,
the bourgeois image of
the earthly paradise.
That is what it's like
to have a nice home, uh,
and some free time in it.
Uh,
it's a poem that Stevens
wrote in his twenties, uh,
in the earliest phase of his
career. Uh, like Elliott,
like frost, uh, Stevens went to Harvard,
uh, that all of these modern
poets went to Harvard. Uh,
he was from early on divided in his
ambitions between poetry and the law of
securely masculine pursuit.
Uh,
Steven's tried journalism
briefly, uh, in New York,
uh, and, uh, legal practice before.
Eventually he entered
the Hartford accident and
indemnity company in our state,
uh, where he remained for
the rest of his life, uh,
becoming a national authority
on Surety bonds, uh, and,
uh,
leading an extraordinary divided life,
a life in which poetry was
identified with leisure in repose.
Uh, there's a kind of, um, sybaritic, uh,
quality to, um, uh,
Stevens, his imagination.
He luxuriating, uh, in another
one of those, uh, Dad Gea,
he says a poem is a cafe. Uh, and,
and so it is, and Stevens, this case, uh,
poetry represents a kind of release
from a objective disciplines, uh,
including the 19th century Protestant
injunctions to refuse private pleasures,
uh, to save for future life. Uh,
perhaps a life beyond
life, uh, in afterlife.
This is the quote puritanism that crane
objects to early in his career and,
and, and, uh, uh, fights against, uh,
and Stevens to a,
is here in a more cautious,
uh, a way, uh, struggling
against it. On, um,
two 38 in the second
stanza, this poem, he says,
[inaudible],
why should she give
her bounty to the dead?
Why should she give,
uh,
why should she give her her spirit?
Uh,
her imaginative investments,
her hopes, uh, to,
uh, uh, the dead, uh,
here, uh, suggesting both,
uh, the dead Jesus and, uh, also, um,
uh, a future life beyond life. Um, uh,
that Christianity would look towards.
Uh,
Steve Stevens is, uh, imagining, um,
earth itself as where bounty is given
and where it should be bestowed.
Uh, it is, uh, it's where we are. Uh,
and, and he'll go on and
describe it, uh, in this stanza.
What his divinity, if it can come
only in silent shadows and in dreams,
shall she not find and comforts of the
sun and pungent fruit and bright green
wings or else in any bomb
or beauty of the earth.
Things to be cherished
like the thought of Heaven.
No. You know, divinity can't be off
somewhere else. It can't be beyond life.
Divinity must live within herself.
And what form does it take?
Their passions of rain or
moods and falling? Snow?
Grievings and loneliness are unsub dude.
Elations when the forest blooms gusty
emotions on wet roads at autumn nights,
all pleasures and all pains remembering
the bow of summer and the winter branch.
These are the measures destined
for her soul. Uh, here,
um, uh, uh,
divinity must live within the person,
uh,
in her subjectivity, uh, uh,
subjectivity that's modeled on and
represented as a version of the sexual
encounter with the seasons,
uh,
which are themselves revolving
and balanced and cyclical.
Uh, uh, the bow of summer
and the winter branch,
uh,
to say that paradise must be here
on earth is also to say that,
um,
uh,
it must include death and dying.
Uh,
a world of,
uh,
change a world that's always in
a sense passing out of existence.
Um, and, and Stevens says in, in, uh, uh,
stands a six, uh, oh,
excuse me, uh, stands a
five, but in contentment,
she says,
he says with her,
I still feel the need of
some imperishable bliss.
Death is the mother of beauty.
Hands from her alone,
she'll come fulfillment to our
dreams and our desires. Uh,
yeah. Paradise. Uh, uh,
if it is to exist on earth, um, uh,
must include death in it.
And,
uh,
as the poem moves towards it's close.
That's what Steven's imagines for us.
Uh,
it's also, uh, well it's a scene
that he leaves us with in the eight
eighth stanza, or excuse me. Um, yeah,
eighth stands, uh, uh, uh, it's
a scene of a world of plenty,
uh, a beautiful world, but also a,
a world which for these
reasons includes death in it.
Um, let's, let's look at that.
It returns to the opening lines of the
poem and then the camera pans out to give
a view of the landscape
in the world around us.
She hears upon that water without
sound and voice that cries.
The tomb in Palestine is not
the porch of spirits lingering.
It is the grave of Jesus where
he lay the tomb is empty.
Jesus is,
is not a presence for us.
And now Steven's moves for the
first time in the poem, uh,
out of that, um, uh, third person,
she to speak in the first person,
plural.
We live in an old chaos of the sun
or old dependency of day and
night or island solitude,
unsponsored free of that
wide water in escapable.
We live in an old chaos of
the sun. We live in a, um, uh,
a world that is material.
Uh,
it exists as a,
uh,
a set of rocks blasted a
across the universe, uh,
that the sun structures and radiates,
uh,
even as Stevens makes this declaration
characteristic of him is the resistance
to residing in any one formulation.
So he'll say one thing and
then he'll say another or,
and notice this pattern a here where he,
uh,
in fact gives us two oars,
old dependency of day and night. That's
another way of imaging our world, uh,
where day and night.
These essential contraries,
these essential natural forms
are dependent on each other,
are constituting each other continuously.
Uh,
we are dependent on them.
They are dependent on each other.
We exist or perhaps in island solitude,
a here the world,
the globe,
this natural space, this earthly
paradise is an island, uh,
in a solitary one, uh,
one without God out there,
uh, in, uh, in, in what, uh, uh,
condition Stevens we'll call
unsponsored and therefore free,
uh,
of that wide water in escapable
where that wide water that
was first introduced, uh,
to us in the first stanza of the poem
becomes a kind of image for a silence in
the world, which is the silence
of, uh, uh, lack of, uh,
I think divine language,
uh,
from these generalizations.
Steven's then moves to these particulars.
Deer walk upon our mountains
and the quail whistle about us.
They're spontaneous cries, sweet
berries, ripen in the wilderness,
and in the isolation of the sky at evening
casual flux of pigeons make ambiguous
undulations as they sync downward
to darkness on extended wings.
Steven's is approach finally is
not to generalize about the world,
but to describe it, uh, to uh,
not tell us how things should
be or might be or were,
but rather how they are, uh, how
they are now. And at this moment,
uh, Steven's evokes the world in
a state of fullness of rightness.
Those berries are ripening.
There's deer walking on the mountains.
Uh,
that present tense that he's using
a evokes action that is ongoing,
uh, is, is present. Uh, and yet,
um,
uh,
all these potential satisfactions
that he evokes are colored by evening,
uh, uh, pleasure here, uh,
is shadowed by death, not unhappily. Uh,
but it is the color of the
environment of the evening.
Uh,
the birds,
they make a downward movement
and yet their wings are extended.
Uh, they're undulations are
ambiguous in that sense.
A much as the dependency of day
and night is itself ambiguous.
Uh, you could, you could contrast those
birds with, with heart cranes. Um,
uh, ascending Siegel at the
beginning of the bridge.
This is a different image.
Stephen's is,
is here trying to image
for us a non transcendental
secular vision of the world.
Let's look ahead to another poem,
uh,
poems of our climate on
to 40. Ooh, excuse me.
Two 52,
uh,
another palm exploring
the idea of paradise.
Uh, Steven's means here in that
title the poems of our climate.
He means, uh, America,
uh, our culture, uh, our
environment, our situation.
Uh,
it's a poem that you might read alongside
of home like England by Marianne Moore.
Uh, he also, uh, means, uh,
the poems of our time,
our,
our moment and our time or our moment,
uh,
for Stevens is defined
as a climate, uh, as, uh,
as a kind of, uh, uh,
environment rather than a,
some other kind of overarching way of,
uh,
understanding or defining a,
the present moment.
Uh, it's not, uh, as the
poem unfolds, uh, uh,
a question about nature so
much as a about culture.
Uh,
Steven's will
here explore one of his,
uh,
recurrent impulses that is to
renew poetry by simplifying terms,
by getting down to some, uh, essential,
some primary elements.
Uh,
if Stevens is essential list,
he's also a kind of aesthetic.
Uh,
he can be both a and as,
and even find,
I suppose a kind of a
essential, uh, asceticism, uh,
in this poem exemplifies that
clear water in a brilliant bowl.
Pink and white carnations
the light in the room,
more like a snowy air reflecting snow,
a newly fallen snow at the end
of winter when afternoons return.
Uh, we, we still don't have a main verb
yet. Uh, pink and white carnations.
One desire is so much more than that.
The day itself is simplified
a bowl of white cold,
uh,
cold porcelain low and round with
nothing more than the carnations there.
Uh, this is, this is Steven's.
This is exploring another version
of secularity of the secular,
uh,
giving us a poetry.
It seems as he starts not have ideas
but of things as Williams might approve.
It is a, a world of
white, uh, you, you can,
you can understand the impulse
here as, uh, a version of the,
um, reduction to nakedness, uh, or, um,
uh,
the reduction to primary
terms that image ism seeks to,
uh, accomplish. Uh, and,
and these are in a sense,
you know, precisely, uh, uh, images that,
that Stephens is presenting to us
almost as a kind of still life there,
uh,
that clear water and a brilliant boal
and the pink and white carnations where,
uh, you know, that word
carnation from the Latin, uh,
meaning flesh a evokes, uh, the, uh, uh,
colors of the body,
uh, and, uh, uh, blood,
uh, and of flesh. Uh, and yet, um,
those qualities are here held
in a kind of suspension that is,
um, contains them and, and,
uh, uh, treats them Cooley,
uh, and, and arranges them.
And it's unsatisfying to
Steven's a, the moment, uh,
he has created this still life.
He starts to want to get rid of it.
Uh,
he says,
say even that this complete simplicity
that I've just produced here stripped
one.
In fact of the heat of the flesh,
a stripped one of all ones torments,
conceal the Evilee compounded vital I
and made it fresh in a world of white,
a world of Clearwater,
brilliant edged still one would want more,
one would need more,
more than a world of white and
snowy sense. Uh, and again,
this is characteristic of Stephens
is imagination. If he said one thing,
he will now try something
else. Uh, he will now, uh, uh,
turn his, his strategy and
an in another direction. Uh,
he continues here. Uh, affirming
powers of mind.
There would still remain the never
resting mind so that one would want to
escape,
come back to what had
been so long composed.
The imperfect is our paradise.
Note that in this bitterness delight,
since the imperfect is so hot in us,
lies and flawed words and stubborn sounds
that never resting mind always wants
more even as it wants to get down to
primary terms. It then once more, again,
paradise is the imperfect,
uh,
the imperfect meaning. Again,
Stephen's is always playing on Latin.
I think,
uh,
the imperfect is the incompleted.
Uh,
the not finished the ongoing, uh, and,
and, and to there, there's tinge is
in that word, imperfect of corruption,
of fallenness, uh, of well flaws, uh,
as Stephen's, we'll go
on to to say, um, uh,
the imperfect does something that's not
cold, but it's hot as people are hot.
It's hot with desire.
It's the heat, uh, uh,
heat of desire that that
shows itself as Steven says,
in flawed words and stubborn sounds.
Uh, Steven's affirms the, the
never resting mine, but above all,
he, he, uh, affirms a
kind of continuing, um,
impulse,
uh,
and demand to speak to find
flawed words and stubborn sounds.
Uh,
over the course of the poem,
Stevens moves from a still
world to a world in action,
and he moves from a world,
uh,
that is visual to a world that is verbal,
that's linguistic, uh,
here, uh, and elsewhere.
And Steven's language is the privileged
medium of human desire and aspiration.
Uh, uh, it's, it's what
gives us delight, uh, his,
his word here. Uh, it
gives us pleasure, uh,
and in this sense, uh, it
remains language does, uh,
on the side of leisure, uh, and, uh,
play a rather than a,
of discipline and work,
uh, in yet, uh, also, uh, no, uh,
the implications of those adjectives,
a flawed,
flawed implies craft some
kind of making I think,
uh, and stubborn, stubborn
suggests perseverance,
discipline, uh, uh, perhaps,
surprisingly a kind of
continuing will, uh, uh, to,
well,
not to rest and to go on speaking.
Uh,
these values that emerge in this poem,
uh, are, um, well they're
recurrent and Steven's,
you'll find him exploring
them, celebrating them, uh,
elsewhere. Uh, let's go forward, uh,
to the poem called the man on the dump,
a on two 54 a for another
poem.
Again, uh, exploring and affirming, um,
certain capacities of
language. Uh, this is,
uh, this is Steven's, uh,
at play in, in the landscape
of the wasteland, if you like.
Stephen's, you know, letter
explains that on his way to work,
he walked to work, uh,
from West Hartford to, um,
uh, downtown and he would, um, uh,
observe during the depression.
Uh, a man on the dump, uh,
and, uh, compose. This
poem prompted by him.
Day creeps down,
the moon is creeping up.
The Sun is a coral Bay of flowers.
The Moon Blanche of course,
she's blanched.
It's the white moon
places there a bouquet.
Ho Ho.
The dump is full of images,
just like the wasteland days
past like papers from a press.
The bouquets come here in the papers,
so the sun.
And so the moon both come and
the janitors poems of every day.
The wrapper on the can of Pairs,
the cat and the paper bag,
the course of the box from Astonia,
the tiger chest for tea.
If Steven's celebrates a desire,
uh, celebrates consumption,
uh,
and sensual pleasure as he does well,
that makes a certain
amount of garbage, uh, uh,
that makes a certain amount of waste.
If you are
constantly seeking
new ways of phrasing and
understanding the world,
you're going to have to be getting
rid of the ones you just had, right?
The ones that you were just using.
Uh,
and the dump is an image of this which
Steven's conference here with a certain
kind of irritation.
Playful,
but not so far, I think from despair. Uh,
the dump is a place of old poetry,
uh, and of course, Stevens.
His own poetry doesn't
want to end up there,
or maybe it does.
Since Stephen's is able to find in the
dump a certain kind of regenerative
power, uh, the freshness of night,
any poet knows,
has been fresh along time.
The freshness of mourning,
the blowing of day one says that it
puffs as Cornelius knee puff reads,
it puffs more than less than,
or puffs like this or that.
Maybe it's just all air. Uh, uh,
these poems
Stephen's is,
is talking about the problem of cliche.
He's talking about,
uh, um, well, the way in which, uh,
any formulation, uh, dies becomes frozen,
becomes a bouquet you must throw out.
Uh,
this is a condition in the wasteland
that Elliot profoundly mistrusts.
Uh,
Steven's on the other hand,
a season it,
a potential for a vision of
the self that is consoling,
uh, and is powerful. Steven's,
uh,
generates as the poem goes on.
Uh, a, um, an image of,
of the poet as a man on the dump,
a one who beats in old tin
can and makes stubborn sounds,
which are are, uh, if you like
sounds of his own stubbornness.
Uh,
Steven's is willing as Elliot is not
to make belief be a personal thing,
a to B something that each
of us constructs a out of
our own will in our own
powers of speech.
It's the palm develops,
uh, Steven's goes through
a, uh, kind of, uh, uh,
a gesture of throwing things out,
a kind of reduction to primary terms
that is like the poems of our climate,
uh, as, uh, around line 21 or so. Uh, uh,
he says now in the time of spring as
alias Trillium's myrtle over Burnham's
daffodils blue flux, you know, all the
names between that disgust in this.
And I think there is discussed in the
palm between the things that are on the
dump, azaleas and so on, and those
that will be as aliens and so on.
When feels the purifying change.
When rejects the trash
and as one rejects the
trash, as one, uh, uh,
gets down to some kind of a primary
whiteness,
some kind of fresh seeing of the world,
we then start to see the moon and
perhaps a different terms, uh,
not merely as blanche. Uh,
you know, uh, some, uh,
uh, uh, old, uh, uh, lady from, uh,
poems from the past, but
perhaps in some new terms, uh,
Steven says that's the moment when
the moon creeps up to the bubbling of
bassoons. That's the time when looks
at the elephant colorings of tires.
Even this, this ugliness
is interesting. Uh,
everything is shed.
The moon comes up then as the moon,
cause all it's images are in the dump.
You have to see it freshly. And you see,
because you're seeing
freshly now as a man,
not like an image of a man.
You see the moon rise in the empty sky,
one sits and beets and old tin can Lard
Pale when beats and beats for that.
Which one believes
that?
What one wants to get near?
Could it after all be merely oneself
that you want to get near,
that you need to get near.
Okay.
Stephens is willing to say yes.
Whereas Elliot is, is as I say,
frightened of this prospect,
uh,
merely oneself as superior
as the ear to a crows voice.
Did the Nightingale torture the ear,
pack the heart,
and scratch the mind and does the
ear solace itself and peevish birds?
Is it peace?
Is it a philosopher's honeymoon?
One fines on the dump?
Is it to sit among the mattresses
of the dead bottles, pots, shoes,
and grass and murmur?
Aptist eve
is it to hear the bladder of grackles
and say invisible priest is it to eject,
to pull the data pieces and
Christ stands on my stone.
Where was it when first
heard of the truth? The Va?
Yeah.
It's a wonderful poem that's
on the verge of nonsense.
Uh, that's on the verge of a kind
of personal language that, as I say,
is an apocalyptic thing in the wasteland.
But is here a source of energy
and power and play for Stephens?
Stephens is not afraid of nonsense.
He's not afraid of
idiosyncrasy of expression.
Uh,
he is willing to play with words.
A linguistic play puts
Stephen's in touch with, um, uh,
kind of, uh, uh, primal poetic resource.
Uh,
Steven's understands truth as
something that is linguistic.
It's something constructed
in and through language.
Uh,
it is therefore perishable.
it is also for the same reason renewable.
Uh,
look at that last line.
Where was it when first heard
of the truth, the, the, the,
the, if you prefer, um,
that last sentence fragment, the, the,
is it, what is that? Is that, uh,
an answer or a clarification
to the question?
Where was it when first heard
of the truth? Now there's,
where did this idea of truth
come from to begin with?
Where did you get that idea?
Why do you want it?
You want it because it is something
that you have heard about. Uh,
it is something that has been spoken.
Uh,
it has come to us as
language has framed it. Uh,
the, the, the definite article,
it's the definite article that makes
the truth the truth. Otherwise,
it would be merely only what a truth
that is to, uh, indicate, uh,
and declare truth in its
singularity, uh, to, to, uh,
uh, uh, uh, give it this, uh,
status that is linguistic act.
The truth is the function and Steven's
understands it of a certain linguistic
capacity, uh, in this
case of verbal formula,
uh,
which takes priority ultimately over
any specific content or doctrine.
Any truth, uh, in that sense,
the truth lies in the Va.
The Va is here representative of
the Human Capacity for declaration,
uh,
for statement a specifically
verbal and linguistic power.
Uh,
the truth that it represents is
not in any sense of final term,
a last word,
a doctrine,
a particular content of
any kind. Uh, instead,
it points to a, a way of
thinking, a medium of thought,
a medium of thought and desire,
a process which is a process of naming,
uh,
or a Stevens who would also call it in
a of modern poetry and active finding.
Uh, this is what, uh,
language does in Steven's, uh,
it creates the world. It
finds the world, uh, it, uh,
constructs the world
through, uh, such, uh,
elementary terms, uh, as the
definite article. Well, uh,
we'll hear more about,
uh,
the implications of this
perspective on experience,
uh,
next time and following.